bill Livingston Cleveland Plain Dealer
columnist joins us now bill good morning
thanks for joining us where do you rank
LeBron James 7 performance well first of
all I'd add this the seventies Knicks on
passing the ball and that's very good
point about Portland Knicks you know hit
the open man and and nobody shot deep
like that because now they've had the
three in college in high school for 30
years Game seven of this series the past
series yeah well you know he's had a lot
of turnovers because of the minutes he's
played I wouldn't put it up there with
with with Game seven of the finals when
he had a triple-double though and I
think only only James Worthy and and
Jerry West who heard your comment Jerry
West was MVP and defeat in 1969 and
that's just preposterous to call mr.
clutch a guy who didn't come through
didn't have a sporting cast just like
wilt didn't have the supporting cast
Bill Russell did and LeBron doesn't have
the supporting cast Golden State does I
thought Indiana the seventh game against
Indiana when finally the Cavs had some
guys chip in what's the best played game
it was very tense it was a four-point
game it was really seven all the depot
hit a three at the buzzer but you know
the Cavs won their four games by a total
of fourteen points I thought that was
the best played game but that seventh
games are like that you know the the
Celtics panicked when they got behind
they were young and inexperienced with a
great future but it just wasn't now and
the Cavs had been there and they had the
best player on the floor and as tyloo
said afterwards his mentor's Doc Rivers
doc always said in a seventh game I want
the best player on the floor on my team
you look at the supporting cast with
LeBron James and we sort of go back and
forth that it's not good but then they
do something we say well it's better
than we thought and how do you think
history's going to look at this
supporting cast with LeBron probably the
weakest since the DOE 17 which was one
of the weakest finalists ever now loves
better than anybody else they had other
than LeBron on that team I guess the
second-best player on that team was
probably Z was doing it so gasca's loves
better than that but you know I don't
think there's much chance in this series
because it's the best team
against the best player but you know
LeBron can't do it all and you know
since it was unlikely in 2016 I know it
was 1% chance when they were down 3-1
but they still had herbing then and
Golden State had matted durant and that
just changed everything
durant more than losing irving that's
that just changed everything he went to
a 73 win team how you know they're
always going to be favored and also by
the way I thought Houston had a lunatic
game plan when you've missed 27 in a row
it's time to start shooting mid-range
well bill I said you know any shooter
will chill right they're very boring
they really are boring yeah but I want
you to at least get a foul your eye I
was always taught if you're not making
your jumper at some point get a foul get
to the free-throw line yeah just get
some rim get to the line yeah that's
that's one of the things with love
people people here have dumped on love a
lot well he gets yet 10 plus rebounds a
game and he does get to the line not
like LeBron does but the second most on
the team he contributes to the victory
and he said he's a smarter player than
those Houston guys chucking and ducking
his availability for Game one when will
when you guys we won't know there's a
conference call with tyloo's before noon
I guess there'll be an update then I
have not seen anything but I've been in
and out this morning the last line of
your column you wrote behold the best to
play the game ever that's how I feel
when did you come to that conclusion
during this playoff run it's just you
know four games of 40 or more three
triple-doubles missed a triple-double in
Game seven the other night by one assist
and that was because nobody could make
shots you kind of had a mini version of
the of Houston's three-point shooting by
both teams you know I I saw a very funny
thing by a friend of mine on Facebook
about it was Michelangelo versus da
Vinci and I said well a Brian would have
to be Michelangelo because he's got the
body for the Sistine ceiling and he
could also PMS pain and sculpt or
passing and score
yeah
but bill you can't have somebody named
Michelangelo not be Michael Jordan well
you're probably right but I was I was
training for a bad pun okay but you know
I think LeBron is probably if he doesn't
get hurt and he's never been hurt knock
on wood
we'll probably wind up the all-time
leading scorer in the NBA and he's a
he's a passer I mean he passes like
magic it's it's like what Chi Chi
Rodriguez said about Nicolas he's a
legend in spare time designing golf
courses that's LeBron he's gonna break
the scoring record even though he looks
to empower his teammates
I also brought but I brought this up
that and I don't want to get into the
LeBron versus Jordan until LeBron is
done like I'm tired of it now I'm gonna
wake up till LeBron is all done but I
look at LeBron in a similar way that I
look at Tom Brady I want to give you
credit for playing four championships
you know Michael and Joe Montana always
had you know people would argue for them
would always say may never lost and
that's true but I gotta give you credit
for getting there even if you do like
there's no shame in what Brady did in
the Super Bowl this year he threw for
500 yards
he's Brady's five and three worse than
four know by Montana I don't think so he
got there more time I know
and there's one one more you know
something to be said about getting there
and I think LeBron I think the critics
are gonna be waiting for him to lose if
he loses in five or god forbid he gets
swept and then all of a sudden you know
this is bad for his legacy to get to
another NBA final I know and you know I
I I think his legacy was secured not
only when he gave a chance abroad
championship to Cleveland after
promising it and after coming back and
an act of redemption and reconciliation
between fans and media here and himself
but just by the way he's conducted
himself off the court I mean I know you
just look at between the lines but it's
never been in trouble with the law
enormous amount of charity work in his
hometown and in the whole area
and I'm inspiration to disadvantaged
kids all over the country two weeks from
now what are we talking about in
Cleveland with the Cavs
what LeBron will do and the in free
agency and who they'll take in the draft
I don't think they're going to win the
series I think it'll be the gentlemen
sweep five games but also there's this
eighth pick enough is there anything you
know iodide they were of all year you
know and they've been insanely lucky and
in the lottery up had they taken Oladipo
and not Anthony Bennett one of the busts
of number one of all time they would be
in a different situation now but they
did get Kyrie Irving and of course
LeBron and they got Andrew Wiggins which
was the you know bait to trade for love
so they've been insanely lucky but they
needed to get they were really hoping
and they could have got in the top three
and gotten somebody to say look LeBron
look what we got now could you see a
scenario where he just signed a one-year
deal to stay in Cleveland to kind of
figure out what the Lakers are doing or
you know I don't see him going to the
west really it's just so much harder to
get to the finals there although it's
gonna be hard with with Boston and
Philadelphia as you say yeah you know I
he is really torn I think between head
and heart he he does not want to uproot
his family again he speaks very movingly
about the relationship with the fans
when he when he left up on the table
scores table after the buzzer beaters he
said they know me they've seen me since
I was a kid I don't think he wants to
move but you know the the deteriorating
competitiveness of the Cavs and they
increased the competitiveness by
increased personnel by other teams may
lead him to I don't know what he's gonna
do the kind of shrugging off Dan Gilbert
the owner with a handshake
after the game does that I know they
don't have a good relationship but no
they don't have a good relationship
you know Gilbert sent out a very
ill-conceived tweet that I've gotten in
trouble for too by criticizing the
circumstances under which I thought it
was sent out and I'm not going to repeat
it because I don't want to get in
trouble again but you know I Gilbert
Gilbert is probably a popular owner with
fans because he will pay whatever it
takes or she also owns a casino and only
Donald Trump went bankrupt with casinos
but that I know love but anyway you know
I don't think LeBron likes him at all I
don't think he's very popular with a
team for letting for driving off a very
good general manager and David Griffin
but you know he does pay them and I'm
sure they every two weeks I'm sure they
like him a lot bill good stuff have fun
during the finals and thanks for joining
us again all right thank you Dan thanks
for having me bill Livingston for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]